mes chers collègues je souhaite en votre
nom à tous la bienvenue à Monsieur
Pierre Moscovici premier président de la
Cour des comptes monsieur le Premier
Président la présentation de votre
rapport est toujours à un moment
important de la vie parlementaire il est
clair nos débats et nourrit les
réflexions qui animent notre assemblée
je tiens à saluer la qualité des travaux
de la Cour des comptes qui nous
permettent de mieux contrôler l'action
du gouvernement et de mieux évaluer les
politiques publiques votre assistante ce
matérialise également par votre mission
annuelle de certification des contes de
l'Assemblée nationale votre appréciation
impartiale contribue à la transparence
que l'Assemblée doit aux citoyens
qu'elle représente sans plus attendre
monsieur le Premier Président je vous
donne la parole
[Applaudissements]
pluie de la Cour des comptes
madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale mesdames et messieurs les
députés en application donc de l'article
l143-6 du Code des juridictions
financières j'ai eu l'honneur de pour
remettre à l'instant il n'y aura pas
plus annuel de la Cour des comptes je
vous remercie de l'accueil qui est
réservé à la cour lequel traduit la
qualité des liens qui unissent nos deux
institutions et vous savez à quel point
je suis attaché du rôle de la Cour à
l'égard du Parlement la course définit
depuis Philippe Seguin qui m'a
équidistance entre le gouvernement et le
Parlement et sa mission d'assistance au
Parlement et pour nous totalement
essentiel j'ai le grand plaisir à
retrouver votre assemblée en séance
publique pour présenter ce qui est
toujours le vaisseau amiral de toutes
nos productions le rapport public annuel
pour cette année 2023
cette année c'est un rapport particulier
puisque la Cour a fait le choix de
porter son travail sur le bilan de la
décentralisation un sujet majeur qui
intéresse hautement nos concitoyens et
qui je le sais naturellement intéresse
les élus que vous êtes quelques mots
peut-être sur le contexte de ce rapport
publique annuel 2023 tout d'abord dans
la suite du rapport 2022 qui avait été
consacré à la réponse de l'État face à
la crise sanitaire cette publication
n'est plus qu'elle fut dans le passé
c'est à dire un assemblage de nos
productions elle se fait désormais sous
un format thématique c'est une
orientation que la Cour a souhaité dans
le cadre de son projet stratégique de
modernisation pour centrer ce rapport
sur une problématique unique c'est une
évolution qui est due aussi au fait que
désormais nous publions tous nos travaux
depuis le 1er janvier 2023 et donc il y
aurait pas de sens à faire une sorte de
patchwork dès lors que vous prouvez
trouver pratiquement 200 rapports par an
public de la Cour des comptes
cette vision 2023 est consacrée les
décentralisations 40 ans après le
lancement de processus par l'adoption de
la loi du 2 mars 1982 relative aux
droits et libertés des communes des
départements et des régions c'est ce
qu'on appellera par la suite de l'acte 1
de la décentralisation ce fut une
rupture historique évidemment avec la
transition tradition centralisatrice
française qui visait à donner aux
collectivités territoriales la maîtrise
de leur devenir et leur permettre de
rapprocher l'administration des
administrés ce mouvement c'est dans un
premier temps concrétisé par ce que nous
connaissons tous c'est-à-dire la fin de
la tutelle des préfets sur les
collectivités locales le transfert des
fonctions exécutives vers les
départements et régions et un nombre
important de transfert de compétences la
cour dresse un état des lieux de la
performance de l'organisation
territoriale actuelle de notre pays qui
est héritière de ce long mouvement
maintenant décentralisateurs et elle
confronte les réalisations avec les
ambitions initial de cette politique
c'est un sujet soumis à controverse sur
lequel la Cour a voulu apporter un
éclairage comme au fond une contribution
à l'objectivation du débat nous avons
identifié les principaux enjeux sous
l'ordre qui est le nôtre c'est-à-dire un
angle financier mais aussi sous l'angle
institutionnel nous avons présenté une
série d'exemples concrets des forces et
des faiblesses de cette organisation
pour la qualité et l'efficience des
services rendus à la population ce thème
a aussi naturellement renforcé la cour
et les chambres régionales des comptes
que vous connaissez bien dans vos
différentes territoires
imbriqué encore davantage leurs enquêtes
9 des 10 chapitres de ce rapport plus
Canuel sont issus de travaux réalisés
conjointement par la Cour des comptes et
par les Chambres régionales et
territoriales des comptes au total 13
chambres régionales et la cour
territoriale de nouvelle Calédonie ce
sont mobilisés autour de ce rapport et
cette évolution c'est-à-dire
l'imbrication entre la cour et les
changements générales va se renforcer
encore puisque grâce à la loi 3DS vous
savez que les chambres régionales des
comptes pourront désormais procéder à
des évaluations de politique publique
locale soit de leur propre initiative
soit à la demande des grands exécutifs
locaux comme chaque année ce rapport
publique annuel est précédé d'un
chapitre introductif relatif ou finance
publique chapitre limitaire dont à nos
yeux la présence est indispensable dans
la période que nous traversons tant la
situation des finances publiques
conditionnent la conduite de la
politique de la nation étant son
actualité s'avère sérieuse je souhaite
donc d'abord vous livrer nos grands
messages sur la situation actuelle de
nos finances publiques elle était déjà
dégradée avant la pandémie de covid-19
il nous semble maintenant des mesures
sérieuses et urgentes comme j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire devant la première
ministre lors de notre rentrée
solennelle il y a quelques semaines
comme je m'en suis entretenu avec le
président de la République lorsque Julie
est remis ce même rapport le
redressement des finances publiques est
le message fort de la cour ça ne
surprendra pas naturellement c'est notre
rôle mais je pense que c'est aussi une
priorité nationale et ça passera
inéluctablement par une revue de nos
dépenses et par un renforcement de la
qualité de la dépense publique la courbe
prône pas l'austérité la Cour ne prend
pas le rabot ou je ne sais quelle hache
c'est pas de ça dont il s'agit la Cour
préconise d'examiner sérieusement la
qualité de la dépense publique pour
réformer les politiques publiques et
infinies voir comment on peut maîtriser
leur coût après 2021
qui fut l'année du rebond de l'activité
économique l'année 2022 a été celle la
première ralentissement celle de
l'inflation surtout ça n'a pas permis
d'améliorer substantiellement le déficit
public le choc sur les prix de l'énergie
et les conséquences de la guerre en
Israël ont ramené la croissance à
2,6%, c'était en deçà des 6,8 de 2021
qui étaient à rattrapage exceptionnel
par rapport à la terrible année 2020
l'économie française a heureusement
montré des signaux de résilience en 2022
mais l'inflation c'est peu à peu imposée
dans le paysage puisque vous savez
qu'elle devrait demeurer à des niveaux
élevés en 2023 atteignant selon le PLF
2023 4,2% ce qui est un peu moins que le
consensus des économistes du côté des
recettes publiques le tableau est là
aussi contrasté elles ont conservé
certains dynamismes en 2022 mais
un ralentissement est également à
prévoir pour 2023 le taux de prélèvement
obligatoire à atteint un pic en 2022 à
45,2 % il devrait diminuer en 2023 pour
retrouver son niveau d'avant crise soit
44,7 % or cice les mesures nouvelles en
prélèvement obligatoire de Total
rapporter 5,5 milliards d'euros en 2023
après une baisse de 5,7 milliards en
2022 en ce qui concerne les baisses
pérennes d'impôts certaines ont été
temporairement compensées par une hausse
des recettes liées à l'énergie disons-le
c'est un dynamisme tout à fait
exceptionnel de la recette notamment
fiscale qui a caractérisé les années
2021 et 2022 sans permettre pour autant
une inflexion du déficit du fait d'un
dynamisme tout aussi marqué des dépenses
les cartes et c'est là pour nous le
point le plus préoccupant la dépense
publique continue de croître un rythme
extrêmement soutenu elle a atteint 1461
milliards d'euros en 2021 elles ont
progressé en valeur de 4,3% en 2022 puis
de 3,2% prévu en 2023 le gouvernement a
mis en oeuvre à partir de 2020 ce qu'on
a appelé le quoi qu'il en coûte c'est à
dire un ensemble de mesures importantes
pour soutenir les ménages des
entreprises face aux effets de la crise
sanitaire prolonger ensuite par des
dépenses dites de relance puis de lutte
contre l'inflation le poids de ces
mesures a certes ralenti mais elles sont
quand même très significatives pour vous
les deux chiffres
37,5 milliards d'euros en 2022 et 12,5
milliards d'euros encore en 2023 2022
devait marquer la sortie du crois qu'il
en coûte liée à la crise sanitaire mais
il y a eu le relais d'autres dépenses
celle qui était liée à l'atténuation de
la hausse des prix de l'énergie pour un
total de 25 milliards d'euros en 2022 de
36 milliards d'euros 2023 en parallèle
les dépenses publiques ont été
mécaniquement alourdis également par
l'inflation
et donc je ne veux pas ici lancer un
dialogue avec le ministre de l'Économie
des Finances qui dit que le quoiqu'il en
coûte est terminé c'est vrai que
certaines mesures sont plus ciblées mais
disons que allez ça coûte encore
extrêmement cher près de 50 milliards
d'euros en 2023 donc notre message est
très clair sur ce point l'ampleur de
dépenses engagée au crises sanitaires et
énergétique brouille l'appréciation
l'évolution la dépense publique et si on
défalque pour autant c'est mesures
exceptionnelles il reste 3,5% en volume
en 2022 et 0,7 en 2023 ce qui est au
dessus de ce qui était prévu par la loi
de programmation des finances publiques
aussi tout ceci m'amène à mon dernier
point sur nos finances publiques
auxquelles je suis très attaché on le
sait qu'il a trajectoire de notre dette
là encore les scénarios affichés ne sont
pas extrêmement satisfaisants puisque
les déficits d'abord ont atteint
6,5% 2021
devrait être autour de 5% en 2022 et à
nouveau autour de 5% 2023 un ratio qui
reste assez élevé alors que la
croissance on le sait va se tasser il en
résulte une dette publique qui devrait
atteindre 111 points de PIB en 2023 14
points au-dessus de son niveau d'avant
crise 700 milliards de plus et si on
prend un peu de recul historique si on
se place en 2000 c'est à dire l'entrée
dans l'euro à l'époque la France et
l'Allemagne avait le même taux de
dépublique exactement
58,9% l'Allemagne a pris 10% l'Italie a
pris 40% la France a pris 55%. donc il y
a un effet de divergence et un effet de
stagnation notre endettement qui à nos
yeux est tout à fait préoccupante et qui
traduit une dégradation relative de
notre situation de finance publique
alors je n'ai jamais pour ma part parler
d'un pays en faillite je ne parle pas de
la soutenabilité de notre dette car nous
avons une signature heureusement solide
mais un pays endetté à l'excès ne
dispose pas des marges de manœuvre
suffisantes pour investir à long terme
dans son avenir et si vous pensez si
vous ajoutez à cela qu'une hausse de des
taux de 1%. signifie un surcroît de
charge annuelle de la dette de 31
milliards d'euros à un horizon de 10 ans
et bien il sera très difficile de
financer les investissements assurément
nécessaires qui sont devant nous si on
ne réduit pas cette dette la dette finit
toujours par engorger puis paralyser
l'action publique interdire le
financement d'investissement d'avenir
dont notre pays a impérativement besoin
voilà pourquoi selon nous à des
endettements maîtrisés est indispensable
et ce panorama que je dresse et d'autant
plus sérieux qu'un recul de la
croissance est attendu pour 2023 nous
allons heureusement éviter la récession
je le crois également mais nous
sortirons de cela avec un retour à la
normale est une croissance plus lente
que celle que nous avons connue dans les
années 2020 et 2021 nous ne sommes pas
mesdames et messieurs les députés selon
nous à l'aube de nouvelles trans
glorieuses mais donner de croissance
plutôt molle j'insiste sur ce point la
situation et les perspectives des
finances publiques appellent à assurer
la soutenabilité de la dette publique
c'est un enjeu de souveraineté c'est
pourquoi nous plaidons pour un
redressement sans tarder de la situation
des finances publiques notre constat est
simple et il est constant il tient en
trois objectifs pour la période 2023
2027 réduire sensiblement les déficits
pour repasser nettement et au plus tôt
sous la barre des 3%, la plupart de nos
partenaires le feront non pas en 2027
mais en 2025 amorcé sans tarder la déco
de la dette et puis préserver notre
potentiel de croissance alors quels sont
les pistes que nous proposons nous en
parlons souvent comme mission des
finances d'abord
doit être selon moi résolument mis sur
la maîtrise de la dépense et ça passe
par l'initiative d'une revue de dépenses
prévues par le ministère des Finances
que j'approuve vraiment il ne s'agit pas
encore une fois d'austérité mais de
regarder politique par politique ce qui
fonctionne et ce qui ne fonctionne pas
ce qui est efficace et ce qui ne l'est
pas et en conséquence d'être capable
d'être et nous pouvons le faire souvent
plus efficace plus juste sans être pour
autant plus coûteux et la cour y
apportera sa contribution à sa place
deuxièmement j'appelle c'est un dialogue
que j'ai pu avoir en commission des
finances notamment avec le rapporteur
général notre pays se doté rapidement
d'une loi de programmation des finances
publiques pour 2023 2027 ça n'est pas
anecdotique madame la député c'est très
important c'est important sur le plan
juridique c'est important sur le plan
politique c'est important sur le plan
national c'est important sur le plan
européen il faut qu'elle soit à la fois
réaliste et ambitieuse à l'échelon
national
nous devons à notre sens pour suivre des
réformes d'envergure sans repousser en
fin de période le l'amélioration de
notre dépense publique et de notre
déficit enfin au niveau européen et ce
sera mon dernier point sur ce sujet une
réforme du cadre du gouvernance des
finances publiques doit avoir le jour
avant la levée de la clause dérogatoire
qui est prévue au 1er janvier 2024 il
s'agit d'accès les nouveaux critères
d'évaluation de la dépense sur
précisément le niveau de celle-ci et sur
l'appropriation nationale des différents
règles de finances publiques ça me
paraît constituer une avancée dans le
bon sens et je pense que en définitive
nous appelons à faire converger la
réforme du cadre du gouvernance
macroéconique européenne avec la
maîtrise des dépenses avec la refonte de
grande politique publique pour retrouver
une situation budgétaire assainie encore
une fois
dans son objectif austéritaire mais pour
nous permettre d'investir dans l'avenir
il y a bien un mur d'investissement
devant nous ou une montagne
d'investissement il y a un mur de dette
et il faut organiser le transfert de
l'un vers l'autre les deux ne peuvent
pas croire ensemble il faudra forcément
être moins endetté pour investir
davantage ce constat sur les finances
publiques étant posé nous sommes aussi
intéressés à la décentralisation c'est
l'objet de notre rapport public sur sa
partie thématique et nous avons souhaité
répondre à la question suivante est-ce
que le niveau de décentralisation et
l'organisation territoriale française
ont permis d'atteindre les trois
objectifs fondateurs de ce qu'on a
appelé les lois de faire du nom du
ministre de l'intérieur de 1982
renforcer la démocratie locale
rapprocher la décision politique
administrative du citoyen améliorer
l'efficacité et l'efficience de la
dépense publique notre rapport fait
suite à un premier bilan de la
décentralisation que la Cour des comptes
avait fait en 2009 en 2010
en 2009 donc et
quand sortons-nous d'abord que malgré
les les tentatives de rationalisation
des deux premières étapes de la
décentralisation ce nouveau bilan 2023
montre que les réformes menées depuis
2010 n'ont pas permis de remédier aux
défauts de notre organisation
territoriale faute d'une vision
consensuelle entre les différents
acteurs en d'autres termes l'ambition
d'ouvrir un acte 3 ne s'est pas
matérialiser par la reprise du processus
de décentralisation de manière constante
il y a une série de lois de moindres
portées qui ont traduit un dessin qui
était plus hésitant et parfois
contradictoire quelques exemples la loi
de réforme des collectivités
territoriales de 2010 qu'on appelle RCT
un rationaliser l'intercommunalité et
créer les métropoles celle de 2014 qu'on
appelle Matam celle de 2015 dites notre
ont un brouillage de compétences cette
réalité peut être illustrée le sort des
départements qui ont fait l'objet d'un
double mouvement d'abord de
réaffirmations des compétences puis de
réduction de leur poids enfin plus
récemment les lois de 2018 et 2019 dites
EVL et 3DS repositionne les EPCI au
service de leur commandement mais
développe la différenciation et
l'expérimentation elles ont pour
objectif d'atténuer certains effets des
lois précédentes mais elles n'en ont pas
bouleversé l'économie pour le dire
autrement mon sentiment c'est qu'un
premier mouvement à chercher à renforcer
l'échelon intercommunale et celui des
régions des grandes régions puis un
second au contraire est revenu sur la
demande de proximité et donc le rôle des
communes départements ça va dans les
deux sens et le balancement n'a pas tout
à fait trouvé son équilibre c'est
fluctuation on réduit le succès des
réformes qui n'ont pas franchi un gay
toutefois cette ambition a compromis
l'intention sous-jacente qui était de
supprimer peu auproux un des échelons
l'organisation territoriales c'était
plutôt le département des parcs qui
étaient visés au profit des régions des
métropoles et la refonte de la carte des
régions a mis en évidence la nécessité
de la logique de proximité sans que le
positionnement de cette échelon soit
clair pour autant en outre contrairement
à l'Allemagne ou à l'Italie la France
n'est jamais parvenue à régler la
question du nombre de petites communes
au premier janvier 2022 la France
comptait
34995 communes nous ne sommes plus sur
les 36000 mais la population moyenne est
de 2000 habitants c'est très inférieur à
nos voisins nous savons qu'en matière
d'action publique vous le savez aussi
bien que moi une taille critique est
nécessaire en matière de portage
d'investissement lourd ou de prise en
compte de la complexité juridique et
financière de la gestion locale la
promotion des fusions de communes depuis
la loi de 2015 a connu un succès relatif
2498 communes seulement ce sont
regroupés au sein de 796 comme une
nouvelle et donc nous sommes dans cette
situation là
législateur a entendu réaffirmé le
primat des communes depuis 2019 la
clause de compétences générale des
communes fait qu'elles peuvent
intervenir dans tous les domaines sans
toutefois en avoir forcément les moyens
d'expertise technique dernier point de
notre diagnostic elle concerne l'état
notre sentiment c'est que l'organisation
des services de l'État n'a pas été
adapté pour tenir compte de l'évolution
de la carte des compétences des
collectivités
disons-le la baisse des effectifs a été
portée d'abord par l'échelon déconcentré
plutôt comme l'administration centrale
et notre sentiment j'avais ainsi produit
un rapport à la demande de Monsieur
Darmanin sur les sous-préfectures c'est
qu'on a exagèrement désarmé l'état des
concentrés et que ce mouvement est un
mouvement qui doit à notre sens être
interrompu voire équilibrer quels sont
en conséquence les les
résultats de ces mouvements et
fluctuations un élan initial essoufflé
un paysage institutionnel qui n'est pas
clair des compétences de plus en plus
imbriquée exercée par plusieurs niveaux
de collectivité ce qui génère des
mécanismes de coordination coûteux et
rarement efficaces et puis un état qui
est très demandé mais qui n'a pas les
capacités de répondre à cette demande
nous avons aussi fait un bilan financier
la décentralisation montrant que les
modalités de financement des cotisations
complexifier entre dotation de l'État
d'une part par d'impôts nationaux
fiscalité redevance locale et c'est
aussi une architecture qui est devenue
peu compréhensible pour les décideurs
comme pour les contribuables bref tout
ça c'est aussi traduit par une
augmentation significative des dépenses
locales alors qu'il faut relativiser la
part des dépenses locales dans le PIB
est passé
de 8% du PIB en 80 à 11% aujourd'hui
mais nous restons un pays très
centralisé puisque la moyenne dans
l'Union européenne est à 18% voilà au
total les objectifs la décentralisation
telle qu'ils ont été fictions de 82 ne
sont pas à nos yeux ce panorama global
n'est pas le plus favorable à
l'efficience de la gestion publique
locale à la responsabilisation des
acteurs et à l'intelligibilité de cette
organisation nous avons donné un certain
nombre de coups de projecteurs sur des
politiques qui illustrent ces aspects
divers nous avons regardé les le
développement économique du territoire
l'aide à l'action envers le plus
fragiles on voit bien que là on a des
chefs de fil le région d'un côté le
département de l'autre qui ne sont pas
totalement reconnus comme tel avec un
enchevêtrement d'intervention et de
compétences et du coup nous appelons à
renforcer cette dimension nous avons
regardé des aspects plus positifs comme
la décentralisation scolaire qui a
indéniablement permis d'améliorer les
conditions matérielles d'accueil des
élèves dans les collèges et nous le
disons nous avons su soulever des
problèmes sur la culture le tourisme la
gestion quantitative de l'eau ou là nous
voyons clairement que nous besoin de
renforcer le rôle des communes comme
pilote dans la gestion des déchets
ménagers nous faisons le constat que la
mise en place d'une comédie circulaire
impose d'associer davantage les filières
de production mais aussi les ménages à
la prévention au réemploi et recyclage
enfin nous avons identifié des domaines
de compétences qui ne sont ni
décentralisées ni clairement partagée
pour lesquels l'intervention des
collectivités territoriales et pourtant
le premier plan est confronté à des
défis croissants le premier c'est
l'accès des soins de premier recours où
les collectivités ont parfois pris le
relais de l'État et de l'assurance
maladie voilà madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés notre
rapport au final un site invite à poser
les bases d'une nouvelle étape de la
décentralisation pour revoir la
répartition des compétences entre l'État
et les différents échelons de
collectivités locales pour doter chaque
échelon des moyens qui lui permettent de
les assumer dans les meilleures
objectifs d'efficacité
alors nous savons bien sûr il y a une
réflexion peut-être sur les institutions
à mener que c'est tout sauf simples que
de réaliser cette grande ambition d'un
véritable acte 3 ou 4 de la
décentralisation mais on peut pas
satisfaire c'est notre message d'un
statut quo nous proposons dans le moyen
terme court moyen terme un certain
nombre de direction d'abord simplifier
le partage des compétences et de
responsabilisation des acteurs c'est une
priorité ensuite
approfondir la coopération
intercommunale et la poursuite de la
réduction du nombre de trop petites
communes soit par fusion soit par
création de communes communautés
renforcer le chef de fila en matière de
politique partagée surtout quand on a un
nombre d'échelons importants et et
préciser les modalités de coopération en
évitant les concurrences
inutiles et enfin l'utilisation oui de
la différenciation territoriale des
expérimentations pour tester des
organisations plus efficaces
mieux adapté à diversité des situations
locales l'état quant à lui nous
réaffirmons son rôle il doit plus que
jamais assuré la fonction stratégique de
régulateur et de partenaires des
collectivités le besoin d’état est très
fort dans les territoires on l'a vu avec
la crise sanitaire il est attendu dans
un rôle plus puissant de stratège des
politiques nationales et de partenaires
des collectivités pour ça nous appelons
un réarmement que l'état des concentré
vous le voyez mesdames et messieurs les
députés notre rapport public annuel pour
2023 vise à éclairer un sujet compliqué
que je sais délicat mais dont
l'organisation et la cohérence sont
fondamentale pour l'organisation de
notre pays en 2024 si tout va bien je
reviendrai devant vous sur un sujet
également structurant qui est celui de
notre programme de travail pour cette
année qui concerne l'ensemble des
territoires puisque nous traiterons de
l'adaptation des politiques publiques au
changement climatique vous voyez que ce
choix d'un RPA comme nous disons
thématique
toute une manière de nous montrer encore
davantage au rendez-vous des
préoccupations de nos concitoyens de
leur représentants mais aussi de rendre
des éclairages plus exhaustifs sur les
questions prioritaires à l'agenda de
l'action publique notre maison à la Cour
des comptes se veut une institution de
référence sur les finances publiques
elle veut vous offrir à vous d'abord la
représentation nationale et à travers
vous aussi aux citoyens des éléments de
réflexion objective qui sont bien sûr
soumis à réfutation comme tout élément
du débat public il faudrait quand même
réapprendre dans ce pays débattre de
manière un peu plus sereine je ne
prétends pas avoir ici une vérité je ne
prétends pas détenir une vérité
quelconque je prétends vous offrir des
éléments de réflexion c'est une ambition
qui est à la fois vaste et limitée merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés de votre attention
de la Cour des comptes
la parole est à monsieur Éric Coquerel
président de la commission des finances
de l'économie générale et du contrôle
budgétaire
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur général
chers collègues j'ai surtout basé
mon exposé sur la première partie sur
lequel vous nous avez entretenu monsieur
le Président c'est sur la question des
budgets des finances je dirais que sur
la question de la décentralisation est
très rapidement il me semble que nous
devrions dans les années à venir revenir
sur et peut-être remettre à plat la
manière dont elle a été faite et sur son
organisation actuelle ça me semble être
un chantier absolument nécessaire
peut-être d'ailleurs pour un certain
nombre de raisons que vous avez
explicité
la Cour des comptes émet de nombreux
inquiétudes dans son dernier rapport
annuel j'en partage un certain nombre
l'inquiétude face à l'inflation élevée
4,8% en 2023 et aux excès d'optimistes
du gouvernement dans ces prévisions
économiques
l'inquiétude face à la diminution je
cite excessive et subi des excrétiques
de l'État avec la suppression de 11000
700 x 33 emplois en disant et face à ses
conséquences en particulier sur les
services déconcentrés plus généralement
sur la santé nos services publics
l'inquiétude face aux inégalités de
financement de nos collectivités locales
et à la perte d'autonomie de leurs élus
ou encore l'inquiétude face au manque de
moyens des départements concernant leur
rôle vis-à-vis des publics fragiles et
des soucis de recours d'accès aux droits
et de délais de traitement qu'il
subissent et que je constate moi-même
tous les jours dans ma circonscription
comme beaucoup je suppose d'entre vous
mais pour autant de manière sereine
monsieur le Président si je partage chez
quelques constats je ne peux pas dire
autant des conclusions que la Cour des
comptes en tir
car malheureusement ce rapport appel à
régler nos problèmes économiques en
usant des exacts et même recettes qui
nous ont selon moi conduit à la
situation actuelle qui reste mauvaise
pour le plus grand nombre au fond j'ai
l'impression que votre analyse s'appuie
sur l'idée que une fois la parenthèse
covid finit et bien nous en aurions
terminé avec les nécessités d'un
quoiqu'il en coûte comme si les crises
étaient derrière nous je pense à
l'inverse que les crises parce qu'elles
sont structurelles et très nettement
liées à ce qu'on appelle le
néolibéralisme sont devant nous et que
revenir finalement aux recettes du
néolibéralisme comme si rien ne s'était
passé me semble est un contresens
vous appelez notamment en effet encore
et toujours avec réduire le déficit
public mais sans avoir l'air d'envisager
d'augmenter certains impôts ni de
revenir sur ceux qui ont été supprimés
vous constatez pourtant bien que la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation nous
a fait perdre 2,8 milliards de recettes
en 2022 celle de la redevance
audiovisuelle 3,2 milliards et la baisse
du taux d'impôt sur les sociétés 2,9
milliards sans parler du manque à gagner
de 4 milliards des 2023 à cause de la
suppression de la CVAE en attendant la
suite
force est de constater que ces baisses
et suppressions d'impôts bénéficient
principalement au plus riche tandis que
les impôts indirects et injustes qui
sont rappelons-le les plus importants
proportionnellement comme la TVA reste
intacte et pèse de plus en plus lourd
sur les épaules des classes populaires
donc sans qu'il s'agisse d'augmenter
globalement l'impôt pour le plus grand
nombre il y a une véritable urgence à le
rendre plus juste et plus efficace au
bénéfice de ceux qui subissent ce poids
fiscal et ses inégalités depuis des
années
j'ai bien entendu le président de la
Cour des comptes pierre Mosco ici faire
par ce week-end oui je vous écoute de la
disposition de la cour à se pencher sur
les 160 milliards de dépenses fiscale
annuelle pour voir ce qu'il fonctionne
et ne fonctionne pas autrement dit à
remettre en question certaines niches
fiscales néfastes en tout cas c'est
comme ça que j'ai entendu votre
interview ou inutile et notamment
remettre à plat la question du crédit
pour recherche la piste
incontestablement
utile mais je pense qu'il faut aller
plus loin en s'attaquant à ce qui
favorise
jusqu'à la décence aujourd'hui les
revenus du capital
j'attends à ce sujet impatiemment la
sortie de la nouvelle enquête de
l'institut des politiques publiques sur
les revenus et les impôts payés par les
ultras riches en France dont les
premiers chiffres indiquent que pour
l'infi minorité des plus fortunés les
0,00
1% le taux de prélèvement d'impôts se
rapprocherait de 0
c'est là que mon avis diverge avec la
Cour des comptes car au lieu de se
pencher sur ce problème ou au moins
d'appeler à revenir sur les baisses
d'impôts qui ont bénéficié au plus riche
la cour préfère pointer du doigt le
niveau de dépenses publiques qui croit
son OL je cite un rythme soutenu quand
bien même cette évolution de 3,2 % en
2023 est en inflation inférieure à la
croissance économique et que si on met
de côté les dépenses exceptionnelles
liées au crise sanitaires énergétiques
elle n'est plus que de
0,7%. en présentant ces chiffres comme
étant élevés en déplorant la faible
baisse du déficit 5 points entre 2022
2023 et en appelant pas à revenir sur
les baisses d'impôts effectués aussi
injuste et coûteuse soit-elle la cour
passe donc un message clair
c'est encore là la dépense publique qui
est attaquée le gouvernement qui est
d'ailleurs pas trompé et vous venez
d'ailleurs Pierre Moscovici le cité
puisqu'à peine votre rapport sorti
monsieur le ministre des Finances
annonce en conséquence des milliards
d'euros d'économies sur les dépenses
publiques prévues à partir de 204 il
s'agit d'un raisonnement qui s'incrive
finalement dans la continuité directe
des politiques de ces dernières
décennies vous voyez gélatine pas
seulement le gouvernement depuis 2017
celle-ci ont significativement affaibli
la puissance publique et nous ont rendu
toujours plus vulnérable face aux
situations d'urgence et de crise
qu'elles soient sanitaire comme on l'a
malheureusement constaté avec le covid
ou encore environnemental comme nous
l'aura notamment rappelé les incendies
de cet été et la sécheresse aujourd'hui
c'est cette même politique libérale qui
d'un même geste attaque sans cesse nos
mécanismes de solidarité sur lesquels
repose pourtant la cohésion sociale de
notre pays une cohésion de plus en plus
fragilisée par les attaques constantes
contre le système de chômage de santé
des attaques qui se font
systématiquement avec l'objectif de
réduire les dépenses publiques et
spécifiquement celles consacrées à la
solidarité et ce en prétextant à chaque
fois vouloir sauver ces 10 systèmes
ces attaques sont conduites dans un
contexte qui n'est pas anodin on le voit
aujourd'hui à travers les exigences de
plan budgétaires à soumettre pour avril
à la Commission européenne signons la
fin du quoiqu'il en coûte et le retour
de l'objectif de 3% de déficit ainsi
qu'avec les annonces d'un prochain
retour de la procédure pour déficit
excessif ces pressions de la Commission
européenne appelle pour moi deux
constats tout d'abord et évidemment
l'urgence qu'il y a pour les Français
les autres peuples européens à
reconquérir leur souveraineté économique
en changeant les traités austéritaires
qui l'ont été imposés et qui donne
malheureusement une grande part de nous
souveraineté au fond au marché ensuite
et dans le même esprit je constate
l'importance qu'aurait revitive
l'annulation de la dette covid que
j'avais appelé de mes vœux dès en effet
cette dette créer de manière
exceptionnelle pour faire face à une
crise sans précédent était détenue et
reste en partie détenus par nos banques
centrales et aurait donc pu être annulé
sans faire défaut sur les marchés or
depuis la banque centrale à l'époque
pardon répondait soit qu'une dette ne
doit par principe jamais être annulé
soit que de toute façon elle était
finalement sans enjeux puisque les
stocks de la dette n'étaient jamais
vraiment remboursés or depuis la Banque
centrale européenne a décidé de se
mettre à revendre sur les marchés
financiers les titres de dettes de
l'État qu'elle possède faisant peser
pardon à riches que supplémentaire sur
notre économie résultat c'est d'être
covid qui aurait pu et dû être annulé en
raison de son caractère exceptionnel
sert comme prévu de nouvelles outils de
pression sur la dépense publique je
ferme l'apparence
cet exemple illustre parfaitement le
paradoxe dans lequel est coincé le
gouvernement plus on veut jouer aux
élèves de l'Union européenne et du
néolibéralisme plus on se retrouve
coincé dans une spirale infernale de
crise et de déficit qui l'éloigne encore
plus des objectifs arbitrairement fixés
par Bruxelles le problème quand on a
pour seul boussole la baisse du déficit
par la réduction des dépenses publiques
c'est compère nécessairement les
boussels boussole prioritaires que
devrait être l'intérêt général la
justice sociale et la lutte contre la
crise écologique le problème qu'on a
pour objectif sol de réduire les
dépenses publiques c'est qu'il faut
choisir des dépenses à attaquer et des
conséquences à long terme sur lesquelles
fermées les yeux et je vous le demande
après les soignants
les professeurs les chercheurs les
chômeurs les jeunes les précaires les
retraités sur le dos de qui l'état
va-t-il encore bien pouvoir fonctionner
tous ces milliards manquants dans les
calculs sur le dos de qui va-t-on
pouvoir ponctionner des milliards de
dépenses
l'économiste Xavier Ragot disait
clairement ce week-end dans l'opinion je
cite il y a une illusion en vogue qui
consiste à dire que l'on peut augmenter
la qualité de la dépense publique cela
ne fonctionne pas regardez les immenses
besoin de l'hôpital public et du
lucation nationale où il faut augmenter
les salaires il faut aussi financer des
investissements massifs dans la
transition écologique
je vous le demande donc sur le dos de
quelle dépense de fonctionnement
voudriez-vous ou du moins le
gouvernement voudrait encore ponctionner
des milliards à l'heure où toutes les
marges de manœuvre dans ce domaine ont
largement été épuisés au point de nuire
aux investissements que tout le monde
appelle de ses vœux comptez-vous encore
et encore faire de grandes annonces
d'une main pour retirer de l'eau les
moyens et les fonctionnaires nécessaires
pour les faire appliquer je parle moins
à vous monsieur le Président qui au
gouvernement en l'occurrence
compte-t-il par exemple encore mettre de
l'argent dans des dispositifs comme
imprime rénov tout en rognant en même
temps sur les postes de ce sens et
contrôler les fléchies cet argent comme
il a été fait avec les personnel de le
ministère de la transition écologique et
de l'ADEME si les objectifs affichés
sont sincères et que le gouvernement
souhaite vraiment réduire son déficit
tout en investissant dans les chantiers
indispensables à l'avenir du pays la
solution est pourtant simple cette
solution ne se situe pas du côté de la
taxation du travail mais du sel du
capital les unes des journaux vantant
les nouveaux records historiques de
dividendes versés chaque année 200
milliards en 2022 dont 80 milliards pour
les seuls CAC 40
21,7%
des actions du caca 40 appartenant à
trois familles je dis ça pour tous ceux
qui m'expliquent que les actions sont
finalement très dispersées dans des
actionnaires des petits actionnaires y
compris des salariés trois familles
détiennent 21,7% des actions du CAC 40
aujourd'hui
et ce à travers des pires crises que
nous traversons collectivement et qui
devrait donc nous servir d'indice mes
chers collègues monsieur le Président il
faut chercher l'argent là où il est là
où il ne sert à rien et où il coûte le
plus à l'état c'est à dire dans les
mains des actionnaires et des très
grandes entreprises
gavées depuis deux mandats sont
contrepartie de réduction d'impôts s'il
fallait le rappeler les aides aux
entreprises atteignent aujourd'hui 256
milliards en 2021 soit la moitié du
budget de l'État elles ont été
multipliées par 20 en 40 ans avec une
envolée record sous Emmanuel Macron la
redistribution des richesses peut se
faire effectivement d'abord par une
fiscalité et une taxation de ses revenus
mais elle se fait aussi à partir de la
redistribution de la plus-value en
augmentant les salaires en créant les
emplois ce qui crée un cercle vertueux
parce que ça donne plus de cotisations
plus de rentrée fiscale
si l'objectif est aujourd'hui
sincèrement de rendre le budget de
l'État plus efficace le chemin est donc
tout tracé et passe non pas par la
pauvrissement de l'État mais tout
simplement par le partage des richesses
produites je vous le dis mes chers
collègues il est temps de prendre plus
au sérieux les comptes de l'État et de
couper court aux cadeaux inutiles et
sans contrepartie destiné au plus riches
des individus et aux entreprises sans
aucune condition il est temps de prendre
au sérieux l'avenir du pays d'y investir
pour plus de protection et de justice
sociale plutôt que de détruire des
décennies de conquête sociale à coup de
47 ans ou de 49,3 il est temps de
soutenir financièrement nos
collectivités à hauteur de leurs besoins
plutôt que de chercher encore et
toujours la moindre faille ou le moindre
prétexte d'efficacité pour leur couper
des vivres il est temps de prendre au
sérieux les crises sociales sanitaires
écologiques et bientôt peut-être
malheureusement financière qui se répète
s'aggravent et nous attendent
indéniablement et d'armer l'État pour
les combattre et ils survit plutôt que
de l'irandre toujours plus vulnérable il
est temps de se souvenir que de la
dépense publique c'est aussi des
recettes des embauches de la demande et
pas seulement des chiffres en moins dans
la balance il est temps finalement chers
collègues d'en finir avec le
néolibéralisme plutôt que de tenter de
le rafistoler à tout prix après chacune
de ces crises merci
Président je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-René
Cazeneuve rapporteur général de la
commission des finances de l'économie
générale et du contrôle budgétaire
[Applaudissements]
la présidente monsieur le Premier
Président de la Cour des comptes
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances mes chers collègues vous
nous présentez aujourd'hui monsieur le
Premier Président le rapport public
annuel de la Cour des comptes se
rapporte concrétise notamment par son
relais dans les médias la mission dévolu
à la Cour des comptes à l'article 47 2
de la Constitution qui dispose que par
ces rapports publics elle contribue à
l'information des concitoyens
votre rapport se concentre en premier
lieu sur la situation de nos finances
publiques vous nous dites qu'à la suite
des dispositifs d'aide mis en place au
titre de la crise sanitaire puis pour
faire face à l'inflation on le contexte
de l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la Russie
je vous cite 2022 et 2023 devrait rester
caractérisé par des déficits importants
retardant d'autant l'engagement d'une
trajectoire crédible de réduction des
ratios de déficit et de dettes publiques
vous avez raison monsieur le Premier
Président mais que n'aurions pas entendu
si face à ces crises exceptionnelles
nous n'avions pas mis en place ces
dispositifs exceptionnels qui ici
c'était levé contre la prise en charge
du chômage partiel pendant la crise du
covid qui ici s'était levé contre le
bouclier tarifaire pendant la crise de
l'inflation qui
personne protéger les Français protéger
les entreprises protéger les
collectivités territoriales oui nous
l'avons fait et oui nous le revendiquons
et nous l'assumons comme vous le
soulignez ces aides ont depuis 2020 un
coût élevé mais comme vous le signez
également ces aides sont
particulièrement efficaces constatez
ainsi que l'économie française est parmi
les principaux pays de la zone euro
celles qui a le mieux absorbé le choc de
la crise sanitaire l'activité se situait
en France fin 2022 un point au-dessus de
son niveau 2019 ce ratio s'élevé à plus
0,6 pour l'Allemagne plus 0,9 pour
l'Italie et moins 1,3 pour l'Espagne
vous reconnaissez également que notre
pays a connu l'inflation la plus faible
de la zone euro en 2022 en raison des
mesures prises pour atténuer l'impact de
l'augmentation des prix de l'énergie là
aussi je cite votre rapport j'ajoute que
conformément au préconisations du FMI
que vous citez dans votre rapport c'est
dispositifs d'aide sont dorénavant
davantage ciblé je salue votre travail
pour retracer le coût net des mesures de
lutte contre l'inflation qui bénéficient
à nos concitoyens boucliers tarifaire
indemnité carburant etc à nos
entreprises amortisseurs guichet d'aide
au paiement des factures d'électricité à
nos collectivités territoriales
amortisseurs filet de sécurité et j'en
passe puisqu'il faut prendre en compte
les nouvelles recettes publiques assises
sur les profits exceptionnels des
énergéticiens
nous parlons au total d'environ 20
milliards de coûts nets pour chacune des
années 2021 2022 et 2023 reste à
déterminer les effets de la baisse très
marqués depuis quelques mois des prix du
gaz électricité sur le montant des aides
versées et sur celles et sur celui des
recettes le gouvernement nous doit en la
matière une information précise et
régulièrement actualisée
si nous avons alloué beaucoup d'argent
pour ces aides qui étaient je le
rappelle nécessaire cela ne nous exonère
pas de la mise en place d'une politique
ambitieuse déterminée et pluri annuel
pour redresser nos finances publiques et
je vous rejoins Monsieur le Premier
Ministre pleinement sur ce sujet il faut
ramener nos niveaux de déficit et de
dettes sur un chemin raisonnable et
maîtrisé et nous ne parlons pas à l'un
de rigueur nous sommes très très loin
nous en sommes très très loin mais de
sérieux budgétaires simplement vous le
signez soulignez d'ailleurs dans votre
rapport vous estimez indispensable de
mettre en place une stratégie qui
combine redressement résolue des
finances publiques et préservation du
potentiel de croissance à moyen terme
certains voudraient réchauffer de
vieilles recettes 100 fois utilisées en
France et recouviez mais recourir
massivement un impôt a toujours mener au
chômage demain
nous faisons nous le pari de
l'investissement de la
réindustrialisation de notre pays et du
plein emploi nous faisons nous cela nous
pardon pour cela nous devons continuer à
mener des réformes comme celles qui
visent à augmenter la quantité de
travail et sa qualification et à
renforcer notre capacité productive dans
ce cadre l'objectif que nous sommes
fixés et social c'est celui de la lutte
contre le chômage qui est la première
source d'inégalité entre concitoyens
c'est celui du plan emploi et force et
de constater des signaux positifs forts
en la matière ainsi
au dernier trimestre 2022 la France a
connu avec un taux de chômage de 7,2%
son niveau de chômage le plus bas pour
la deuxième fois depuis 40 ans permet
toi permettez-moi également de vous
rappeler qu'en 2016 ce chômage s'élevait
à
10,1% au moment où la nupesse était au
pouvoir malgré les difficultés notre
économie encore créé 44
000 emplois au dernier trimestre 2022
la réforme c'est aussi celle de notre
système de retraite afin de garantir sa
pérennité je pense et vous ne me
contredirez pas monsieur le Premier
Président sur la nécessité de mener une
telle réforme
vous défiez dans la politique de
rétablissement des finances publiques il
nous faut me semble-t-il suivre deux
lignes directrices que vous avez
évoquées tout d'abord mené une revue
exhaustive des dépenses publiques à
échéance régulière je note que le
gouvernement annoncé on s'est début
d'année l'engagement d'une telle revue
dans l'optique de l'organisation
prochaine d'assise des finances
publiques il importe que le gouvernement
nous informe rapidement des modalités et
du contenu du l'exercice qui semble
avoir entamé deuxièmement fixé une
trajectoire pluriannielle dans le
respect de nos engagements européens
alors que l'encadrement communautaire
des finances publiques nationales doit
être rétablie sous une forme rénovée
actuellement en négociation à compter de
2024 dans cette perspective il
m'apparaît comme à vous monsieur le
Premier Président indispensable que nous
puissions prendre appui sur une loi de
programmation des finances publiques je
me réjouis que votre rapport réitère vos
propos tenus à plusieurs reprises en
commission des finances le vote d'une de
programmation constitue un enjeu
d'intérêt national il nous faut remettre
l'ouvrage sur le métier
j'en viens au bilan que vous dressez de
40 ans décentralisation le sujet mes
chers et je crois dans les bienfaits
réelle car je la foi dans la sagesse la
compétence et l'engagement de nos élus
locaux merci à la Cour des comptes pour
ces constats lucides et objectifs sont
la décentralisée décentralisation je
considère que l'action locale doit être
structurée autour d'engagement et de
garantie y compris en matière de finance
publique nous savons tous quels sont les
objectifs de la décentralisation
renforcer la démocratie locale
rapprocher la décision administrative et
politique du citoyen améliorer
l'efficacité et déficience de la gestion
publique et j'y rajouterais adapter nos
politiques publiques aux spécificités de
chaque territoire
en 2009 vous avez fait référence dans le
cadre d'une première étude
dansante sur la décentralisation la Cour
des comptes dressée un bilan contrasté
la lecture aujourd'hui de votre rapport
confirme que pratiquement 15 ans après
non pas permis ces 15 années n'ont pas
permis une amélioration nette de la
situation en témoigne l'abstention
massive aux élections locales la
complexification continue du
millefeuille administratif les
interrogations des élus locaux eux-mêmes
sur le sens et l'efficacité de leur
action pourtant courageuse et déterminée
j'évoque ce point sans aucun esprit de
polémique je crois que la situation
actuelle sédiment des insuffisances
cumulées dans le cas des majorités
politiques très variées en clair sur
beaucoup de politiques publiques nous
avons fait des choses à moitié nous
sommes restés au milieu du gué
vous soulignez également à juste titre
le manque de lisibilité pour nos
concitoyens dû à des compétences
intriquées et un financement complexe
qui paye quoi qui fait quoi qui est
responsable de quoi nous disent nos
concitoyens tous les jours si les
dépenses locales ont fortement augmenté
ces dernières années nos concitoyens
n'ont vu que le recul de l'État et il
s'en plaignent vous l'avez également
souligné nous nous devons je crois
travailler suivant quatre axes
principaux en premier lieu il faut
aligner compétences responsabilité
financement en fait tu te montres comme
par exemple sur les politiques en faveur
du développement économique qu'il faut
autant que possible d'adopter le
principe de l'exercice d'une compétence
bien identifiée par un seul niveau de
collectivité territoriale ce principe
est d'autant plus efficace que la
tentation alternative que nous pouvons
avoir de créer des sénates locaux de
coordination chargés d'établir des
schémas directeurs ou les documents de
planification deuxième axe il faut
simplifier l'organisation mieux
coordonner les interventions et faire
évoluer les modalités d'exercices des
compétences cet appel à la simplicité et
à la cohérence vaut d'ailleurs pour
l'État au premier chef vous montrer que
les politiques touristiques et
culturelles vous prenez ces deux
exemples ne sont pas d'exemples d'action
doublement ce que les collectivités
territoriales met en oeuvre il faut des
chefs de fil clairement
identifiés nous sommes parvenus ces
dernières années à suscité la création
de comme une nouvelle notamment dans la
ruralité et à homogéniser rationaliser
la cape de l'intercommunalité il faut
poursuivre nos efforts pour tenir compte
des nouveaux enjeux du développement
durable et au mur d'investissement
associés par exemple pour la gestion de
l'eau il faudrait adapter notre
organisation territoriale au sous bassin
hydrographique verdissement de nos
politiques publiques trouvera son levier
le plus fort
au niveau local j'en suis absolument
persuadé troisième
axe le rôle de l'État aux côtés des
collectivités territoires doit être trop
penser il doit te recentrer sur son rôle
stratège et favoriser la décision au
plus près des territoires pouvoir des
rogatoires aux normes être attribué au
préfet multiplier les possibilités de
différenciation territoriales loin moins
bavarde qui permet aux élus en lien avec
l'état de faire le dernier kilomètre les
solutions exitent il faut les mettre en
oeuvre enfin le dialogue financier avec
les collectivités territoriales et
primordiales trois années je crois les
filets de sécurité que nous avons adopté
durant les crises sanitaires puis à
l'occasion de l'augmentation des coûts
de l'énergie pour mener sereinement des
politiques publiques locales il faut
donner aux collectivités des garanties
sur leurs ressources la passe par une
refonte des dotations devenue
particulièrement illisible et par la
garantie de leur autonomie financière et
parce que l'État le garant en dernier
ressort
de l'ensemble des finances publiques il
faut aussi désengagements de la part de
nos collectivités territoriales j'en ai
la certitude engagement ne suffit ne
signifie pas nécessairement contrainte
ou sanctions mais en partageant une
trajectoire commune avec un effort
identique que nous arrivions
conjointement c'est en partageant donc
cette effort commun que nous
n'arriverons conjointement à maîtriser
nos finances publiques
vous proposez pour renouer avec les
objectifs de la décentralisation
monsieur le Premier Président la
création d'une instance de dialogue
indépendante entre le gouvernement le
Parlement et les collectivités
territoriales j'y suis évidemment
favorable et disponible c'est une
condition nécessaire évidemment pas
suffisante pour construire une nouvelle
étape de la décentralisation dans un
climat de sérénité de responsabilité et
de confiance réciproque
pour terminer Monsieur le Premier
Président Michel colleg dans un contexte
marqué par l'obligation d'assurer le
redressement des comptes publics
auxquels les collectivités territoires
doivent être associés et par la
nécessité de d'améliorer l'efficacité de
nos services publics locaux la tentation
de l'immobilisme doit être surmontée je
vous remercie
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
général
donc monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Président
l'Assemblée nationale vous donne acte du
dépôt du rapport de la Cour des comptes
la séance est suspendue